bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Luis Muñoz el 29
de marzo de 1973 Estados Unidos decidió
retirar a sus efectivos militares de la
guerra de Vietnam tras años de conflicto
infructuoso contra la guerrilla
comunista de vietcom y el ejército de
Vietnam del Norte una fecha simbólica
que aunque no supuso el final de esta
guerra precipitó el colapso de su Aliado
Vietnam del Sur que solamente pudo
resistir dos años más 50 años del inicio
del final de uno de los conflictos más
costosos en la historia de Estados
Unidos El origen de la guerra de Vietnam
se remonta al año 1946 mucho antes de
que entrara de lleno Estados Unidos tras
la Segunda Guerra Mundial Francia
intentó retomar su control sobre la
colonia de indochina a pesar de las
aspiraciones independentistas de sus
pueblos bajo las órdenes de hoshiming la
guerrilla del vietmin luchó contra las
tropas coloniales hasta 1954 cuando
Camboya laos y Vietnam consiguieron la
Independencia el problema es que Vietnam
quedó partida en dos ya que al norte del
paralelo 17 se creó Un gobierno
comunista y al sur uno Pro occidental el
acuerdo inicial consistía en que
transcurrido un año tras la división los
vietnamitas tenían que organizar un
referendo para votar si querían la
reunificación o mantener la división
pero ante el miedo de que triunfara la
unión y se impusiera el comunismo
Estados Unidos y los sectores
anticomunistas de Vietnam del Sur Se
negaron a hacerlo esto desembocó en un
enfrentamiento directo entre la
guerrilla comunista de Vietnam del sur
llamada vietcon y el gobierno que a
partir de 1959 se convirtió en una
guerra civil el viet contó con la ayuda
de Vietnam del Norte para obtener
suministros a través de la conocida ruta
josesimin este entramado de caminos y
túneles creados durante la Segunda
Guerra Mundial
empleados por la guerrilla atravesaba
laos y Camboya hasta llegar a Vietnam
del sur y sería fundamental en el
transcurso de la guerra gracias a esto
el vietcom llegó a controlar cerca del
60% de Vietnam del sur
llegados a este punto Estados Unidos
llevaba años dando ayuda militar y
económica a Vietnam del sur pero la
situación límite le obligó a intervenir
de forma directa a partir de 1964 esta
intervención se hizo tras el incidente
del Golfo de tonkín un supuesto ataque a
un barco estadounidense que nunca pudo
ser demostrado Estados Unidos comenzó a
enviar decenas de miles de soldados a
Vietnam alcanzando un pico de 539.000 En
1968 la superioridad estadounidense hizo
que en poco tiempo se recuperase una
buena parte del territorio sin embargo
estos militares no estaban preparados
para sufrir la guerra de desgaste que
les plantearía el vietcom en un terreno
tan hostil como la selva vietnamita la
guerrilla comunista incrementó su poder
Gracias al apoyo militar de China y la
unión soviética además evitaba cualquier
tipo de enfrentamiento directo con los
estadounidenses y aprovechaba la red de
túneles y caminos para realizar ataques
sorpresivos que dejaran en mayor número
de víctimas los muertos se contaban por
miles y mientras la paranoia crecía
entre el ejército estadounidense Los
Altos costes de la invasión dispararon
la impopularidad de la guerra
en esto tuvo mucho que ver la televisión
este conflicto fue el primero en
transmitirse de forma casi íntegra a
millones de personas de todo el planeta
que pudieron ver cómo Estados Unidos
bombardeó con napan selvas enteras y
utilizo armas químicas como el Agente
Naranja contra la población una y mala
imagen que forzó a que el expresidente
Nixon planteara La retirada progresiva a
partir de 1969
mis compatriotas estadounidenses estoy
seguro de que pueden reconocer por lo
que he dicho que realmente solo tenemos
dos opciones abiertas Si queremos poner
fin a esta guerra puedo ordenar una
retirada inmediata y precipitada de
todos los estadounidenses de Vietnam sin
tener en cuenta los efectos de esa
acción o podemos persistir en nuestra
búsqueda de una paz justa a través de un
acuerdo negociado si es posible a pesar
de este mensaje Nixon se propuso
terminar con la ruta hoshiming y
emprendió una campaña secreta de
bombardeos masivos contra laos y Camboya
el conflicto se extendió a dos vecinos
hasta ese momento neutrales y laos por
ejemplo se convirtió en la nación más
bombardeada de la historia superando
cuotas de la Segunda Guerra Mundial algo
que no mejoró las cosas ya que la ruta
hoshiming continuó operando y tanto en
Camboya como en laos tomaron el poder
fuerzas comunistas los gérmenes rojos y
el partido popular revolucionario de la
respectivamente
llegado este punto a Estados Unidos
Solamente le interesaba que Vietnam del
sur resistiera lo máximo posible a
través de una ayuda económica y
armamentística por lo que firmó Los
acuerdos de paz de París para
oficializar su salida en 1973 sin
embargo Esto fue una sentencia de muerte
para el gobierno de saigón que se vio
incapaz de resistir frente a las
ofensivas del vietcom y del ejército de
Vietnam del Norte la falta de disciplina
y moral entre las filas Sur vietnamitas
hizo que la guerra apenas durase dos
años más hasta que el 30 de abril de
1975 las fuerzas comunistas llegaron a
saigón
la caída se dio de forma sorpresiva y
rápida y obligó a Estados Unidos a
realizar una evacuación humillante del
personal restante en el país llegando a
llevar helicópteros a su embajada tras
esto Vietnam quedó unificado en un país
bajo mando comunista y Estados Unidos
sufrió uno de los mayores reveses
militares de su historia haciendo que
durante varios años Washington se
replegará en el panorama internacional
con esto concluimos Gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
France 24.com
[Música]